>> WOW WEE!
HONEY, HOW DO YOU KEEP THE HOUSE
SO CLEAN?
>> A LADY NEVER TELLS.
>> A WOMAN'S WORK IS DONE BETTER
WITH GE HOUSEHOLD APPLIANCES.
>> TIMES CHANGE.
AND THESE DAYS, WOMEN ARE THE
PRIMARY BREADWINNERS IN 50% OF
AMERICAN HOMES AND THAT MEANS
HOUSE WORK IS A MAN'S JOB.
SO GIVE HIM THE TOOLS TO GET THE
JOB DONE RIGHT WITH GE'S NEW BIG
BOY HOME APPLIANCES.
LIKE THE BIG BOY DISHWASHER,
FEATURING A 70-POUND STEEL DOOR.
>> I'D LIKE TO SEE A WOMAN DO
THAT.
>> AND HEY, SHE MAY HAVE CLIMBED
THE CORPORATE LADDER.
BUT SHE'LL NEED AN ACTUAL LADDER
TO USE THE BIG BOY WASHING
MACHINE BECAUSE THAT SUCKER IS
SIX FEET TALL.
DIRTY FLOORS DON'T STAND A
CHANCE AGAINST THE BIG BOY
RIDE-ON VACUUM CLEANER.
THAT'S 240 HORSEPOWER.
PURE CHORE TORQUE.
WITH THE DETACHABLE SPOT REMOVER
THAT ABSOLUTELY ANNIHILATED
STAINS.
ALL GE BIG BOY APPLIANCES HAVE
AN ENERGY STAR RATING OF
F-MINUS.
BECAUSE THEY RUN ON GAS.
SO MAN UP THIS HOLIDAY SEASON
AND ASK YOUR WIFE TO BUY YOU GE
BIG BOY HOUSEHOLD APPLIANCES.
>> WOW, HOW DID YOU GET IT SO
CLEAN IN HERE?
>> OH, SORRY, BABE, A GUY NEVER
TELLS.
>> GE BIG BOY APPLIANCES.